everybody is Charlie so we got to talk
about Logan this is going to be my
spoilery review too just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet the movie totally wrecked me for the
second time I've only seen it twice now
but after the second viewing I'm now
saying that this is my new favorite
x-men film of all time hands down
there's no contest Deadpool was sort of
neck-and-neck for a while but it's so
different in so real that I feel like
they're going to be doing this a lot
more in the x-men movies maybe comic
book movies in general and I will
explain some of the logic behind the
Deadpool stinger but I'm waiting for
them to post it online to do an actual
separate video about that but Fox just
totally nailed it with this shot here
it's the perfect bookend for Hugh
Jackman's time as Wolverine and I'll
address some of the things he said about
the future of the character he says that
he's totally cool with them recasting
but there's no way they're going to roll
out a new Wolverine right away so I'll
say new round of the Logan giveaway I'm
giving away IMAX gift certificates
because you absolutely have to see the
movie if you haven't seen it already so
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so I'm going to explain the logic of the
film how it fits into the continuity
it's sort of an adaptation of the x-23
origin story from the comics in the old
man Logan story but it's much more
centered on the x-23 character so the
build picks up in the Year 2029 it's 6
years after the end of Days of Future
Passed
after they fix that timeline but what
has happened since then is that Zander
writes this person here who's running
the offshoot of the Weapon X program
down in Mexico is creating x-23 and all
these mutants he's the one that's
responsible for no new mutants being
born they say no new mutants have been
born in the last 25 years the way they
explain that is that Xander rice is
using stuff like high fructose corn
syrup genetic tampering in the foods you
eat the shampoo that you use in your
hair all of the products that you use in
your daily life to stop the X gene from
proliferating so if you've ever had any
conspiracy theories about the government
tampering with your food this movie will
only make that worse because there's a
really insidious way to kill off mutant
kind in what he explains is is that he
didn't want to kill mutants he wanted to
control
so the task was to kill off all
naturally born mutants so that they
could create artificial mutants that
they would then control turn into
weapons to the highest bidder it's very
Weapon X program the same thing was
happening in the Deadpool movie on a
smaller scale Ajax was creating utens
and selling them to warlords who wanted
to pay for them the other big WTF the
way they explained that the x-men are
dead is that Charles has a degenerative
brain condition so Professor X actually
had some sort of seizure and killed all
of the mutants and about 400 people in
Westchester around the x-mansion within
like the last six years of the movie
it's a relatively recent occurrence what
happened after is that a government
classified his brain a weapon of mass
destruction
so wolverine takes him on the run so
that's where the film picks up he's
caring for Professor X with Caliban
trying to keep him from hurting other
people while at the same time trying to
give him a certain quality of life but
there aren't any tricks it's not in an
alternate universe this is totally in
the x-men timeline but we can talk about
what the future of some of these
characters are like the future of
Wolverine the future of the x-23
character is going to be because a lot
of that depends on how they want to
stick to the timeline whether or not
they want to use cable for time travel
because they've been talking about an X
23 spin-off movie but it gets really
complicated when you try to keep it
still in the future that's way past all
these other x-men movies but I can't say
enough about this film the visual
language is amazing the future of the
x-men movies is not in big blockbusters
it's in movies like this small movies
that make for really good characters
there are so many real moments in this
film the way that Wolverine and
Professor X are I loved his introduction
in the film so you walk in with
Wolverine to this sort of discount
version of cerebro that's meant to
shield everyone else from Professor X's
mind
and he just babbling on like he's
completely crazy it's a very real
picture of a son trying to care for an
ailing father who feels like his son is
just waiting for him to die in the Sun
who feels like his father thinks that
he's a failure so the idea of family is
very important to the x-men films in
general they reference a lot of the
other x-men films when I found you
you were a cage fighter you were an
animal I gave you a family so hands down
one of my favorite scenes in the movie
is when they're having that family
dinner with the people that they meet
and they're sort of joking about their
life together oh you know Charles used
to be a teacher oh yes Logan was one of
my students although he wasn't very good
yeah I got kicked out a few times and it
sort of them just talking about their
lives together this crazy x-men timeline
is if it was just a normal family life
it is the perfect way to eulogize their
time together on this franchise and then
we have to talk about the use of that
Shane movie so the movie that they were
watching when they were in Vegas that
was Shane it's all about this weary
gunfighter who tries to settle down with
a family but this evil Rancher rolls in
and forces him to pick up his guns again
it's literally the plot of the Logan
movie so the Shane movie is the Logan
movie it was just so beautiful the way
they had x-23 eulogized the Logan with
that final quote from the movie there's
no living with with a killin there's no
going back from it in teller tell her
everything's all right in there no more
guns in the valley so the way they use
it in the movie is this really beautiful
metaphor for the end of the weapon x
program don't be what they made you
that's one of his final lines to her so
she's going off to this new life in
Canada and you're left to wonder what
her future is going to be like but the
idea sticks that Shane the Logan
character was successful in his mission
even though he was unable to leave his
life of violence behind but with all of
its hope into the x-23 character
hopefully she will be able to do
something better with her life she will
be able to stop running in the way that
he ran his whole life and I love the way
that she turned the X on his grave your
life meant something you were x-men so
the whole movie is so beautiful and it
isn't all a cry fest like you're not
crying constantly through there's a lot
of humor in there a lot of Wolverine WTF
reaction comedy a lot of family comedy
just with Charles being super old and
cranky and dropping all those f-bombs it
is the realest x-men movie that they've
ever made in the realest comic book
movie that I think I've seen in the last
like five maybe ten years so just
address some
the finer points of the film the reason
that they explain there's no yellow
comic book costume obviously it's
inappropriate for the tone of this film
but in general the logic behind Hugh
Jackman never really wearing the yellow
spandex is because Wolverine isn't a
character that advertises like he
doesn't care about branding and that's
really what happens when you put a comic
book costume on
so that's straight out of the director
the writers mouths if they do find a way
to put him in a yellow comic book
costume in a future movie it would have
to be something like Deadpool it has to
be a completely different film or
something a little bit lighter like the
main x-men films but part of that logic
is also why there was no Deadpool in
this movie they did say that at one
point that there was going to be
Sabretooth in the movie they thought
that it might be fun if while they were
on the road they ran into them they
asked him for some help but then that
got pulled out because there were too
many characters but the film itself is
so serious that it would have been
completely inappropriate to have
Deadpool in it and that's why you know
the final moments that felt you're
bawling your eyes out over the Johnny
Cash that's playing over the credits
putting that Deadpool scene right after
that would have been completely weird it
would have completely undermined the
movie so that's why they played it at
the top of the film in it was totally
hilarious I'll talk about it in another
video who knows that they're going to
post it online they might wait a couple
days to post it but let me know in the
comments what did you guys think about
the film and what do you want them to do
with the x-23 character going forward or
even the Logan character so Hugh Jackman
just addressed his comment has said that
he is totally cool with them recasting
the character but obviously there's no
way that they're going to turn around
and do that Batman style in the next
couple of years maybe in the next four
or five years but I think it's going to
be a long time before we see another
Wolverine in the movies the producers
even said that what if we don't ever do
over een again that would be stupid not
doing him again ever I think they'll
just wait a good long while they have
all these brand new characters Deadpool
blew up they have plenty to work with
right now they don't need to go back to
that Wolverine well right away and they
can do their x-23 spin-off if they want
so what will happen this weekend is I'll
post another video about the future of
the characters we can talk about an X 23
movie how they could fit her into the
other movie
if they want to use time travel or if
they want to be straight up and just
keep it set off in its own little
universe in the future so what's going
to happen next is is unless they
actually do drop that Deadpool teaser
because it's Star Wars Friday I'll be
posting a Star Wars the last Jedi video
later tonight
so my next Logan video will post on
Saturday I'll say congratulations to the
latest Logan giveaway winner usual
suspect please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you win IMAX gift
certificates so everybody be sure to go
see Logan this weekend and if you have
seen it already be sure to go see it at
least one more time because this movie
is amazing while you wait for that you
can click here to rewatch that Aquaman
test footage and you can click here for
the Guardians trailer thank you so much
for watching let's high-five
hi claw I'll see you guys in the next
video
you